[Music]
who do you think the best driver is
probably Rory I would dust him in a lap
yeah all you do is play video games with
some crazy dreams of racing cars you're
the one that told us always do something
we love
listen cars cost
look around it's not our world son
what is this it's a contest
the best Gran Turismo players in the
world
get a chance to compete in professional
racing dude this is real
[Applause]
I'm sorry I really think you're gonna
take a kid who plays video games in
their bedroom you're gonna strap them to
a 200 mile an hour rocket it'll tear
them to pieces
it's not gonna work the guys who race
are Elite athletes but I won't stop now
your kids were scrawny little gamer kids
well that's why you coming come on let's
go
must be a new experience for you moving
your legs
you puked on my lawn there's no turning
back man when you're in a race the
cockpit is going to be 140 degrees
Fahrenheit
g-forces will be twice when an astronaut
experiences upon liftoff I can't see
anything
hey you get extra points for that in the
game Jesus Christ
the couchsurfinger
[Music]
welcome to Team Nissan
what's next it's major leagues the other
drivers are going to hate you
[Music]
racing
the line in the game
I know this track
a bracelet a thousand times
that's what I'm talking about
thank you
[Music]